françois rebsamen l invité de preuves
par 3 ce soir bonsoir merci d'être avec
nous maire de dijon
ancien ministre du travail dans les
premiers gouvernements de manuel valls
et à ce titre évidemment votre avis sur
la loi travail nous intéresse
particulièrement
de même que votre proximité historique
avec françois hollande on y reviendra
dans cette émission vous connaissez bien
le principe de cette émission divisé en
trois parties et il nous faudra répondre
à trois questions principales la
première question peut-on encore sauver
la loi travail alors que le premier
ministre poursuit jusqu'à demain ces
consultations auprès des partenaires
sociaux est alors surtout que nous
sommes à la veille de la manifestation
premières manifestations contre ce
projet de loi
deuxième partie de cette émission avec
notre partenaire l' agence france-presse
stéphanie le rouge viendra vous demander
si le parti socialiste peut mourir tant
le parti apparaît divisée à la fois sur
la loi travail mais également sur la
déchéance de nationalité de la
nationalité pardon également sur la
primaire et puis enfin un troisième
partie de cette émission avec notre
journaliste michaël szames est ce si
vous étiez encore parlementaire encore
fondateur françois rebsamen est ce que
vous voteriez la déchéance de
nationalité
la révision constitue constitutionnel
sera effectivement examinée la semaine
prochaine par le sénat le premier
ministre était auditionné ce matin par
la commission des lois et on a vu qu'on
était encore loin d'une position
convergente avec l'assemblée nationale
alors première partie de cette émission
françois rebsamen première question
peut-on encore sauver la loi travail
votre avis bien sûr non seulement la
sauver mais mieux la présenter
l'expliquer et tenir compte des
remarques des propositions d'amendements
et modifications qui ont été fait ou qui
vont être faits par les syndicats
réformistes dont combien ce sera un
recueil pourquoi un recul
la négociation qui s'ouvre et qui est
celle ouverte avec les syndicats
réformistes les indispensables
elle est avec d'ailleurs l'ensemble des
organisations syndicales et patronales
donc c'est bien de les écouter c'est
bien de les entendre d'avancer des
arguments d'entendre des arguments
contre et je pense qu'il y aura des
modifications qui seront apportées à
cette loi la marquise moi moi même
lamarti pourtant semble mal engagée non
non je ne le crois pas moi même j'avais
émis quelques réserves sur rennes
revenir sur deux voies d'abord sur sur
la présentation qui avait pas été très à
droite et qui faisait peser a priori une
suspicion vous savez c'est dans ce pays
c'est comme ça une suspicion de dérive
droitière du texte présenté pourquoi
parce que je crois qu'il avait été dit
que le gouvernement prendrait ses
responsabilités si nécessaire et donc
été évoquée voilà mais je crois qu'il
avait été formulée comme je lé indiqué
mais la vérité défaut tour première
remarque selon vous c'est le défaut le
manque de pédagogie autour du texte
oui très fort et elle de communication
oui mais je crois que ce texte sorti
alors même qu'il était envoyé au conseil
d'état qui n'a pas encore été présenté
au conseil des ministres
et donc du coup il a fallu remettre
l'ouvragé sur le métier et recommencer
commencer cette erreur de communication
cela je ne sais pas je ne sais pas moi
j'ai la ville de foot non je crois qu'il
ya eu le texte a été envoyé au haut
conseil d'état
vous savez avant on vérifie vous le
savez bien on vérifie que les articles
qui sont envoyées sont conformes au
droit et on prend en compte les
remarques du conseil d'état l'ars avait
même pas le texte est sorti comme ça
brut de décoffrage je ne sais pas
comment ça a pu se faire et donc à
partir de là il faut reprendre le bâton
d'explication pèlerin pour expliquer les
choses dire que ce texte est bien c'est
pas c'est parce qu'on croit c'est pas
une dérive c'est pas le régime a été
fait dans l'arbre du travail normalement
la louve à l'archet impose la
consultation des partenaires
il ya eu ces consultations bilatérales
qui ont été menées pas sur tous les bars
mirex tamar myriam el khomri alors on me
dit qu'il ya eu quelques rajouts de
dernière minute la concertation et
l'élan alors au vu des premières
consultations du premier ministre avec
les partenaires sociaux
cette semaine on constate quand même
encore de profonds désaccords notamment
avec la cfdt
je vous propose françois rebsamen
d'écouté laurent berger le secrétaire
général de la cfdt
nous avons été écoutés il nous a été dit
que la porte était ouverte au dialogue
que des choses pouvaient évoluer qu'il y
avait des espaces et nous a pas été
donné de réponse parce que les les
auditions entre guillemets ne sont pas
ne sont pas terminées mais nous avons
redit notre détermination à agir contre
les mesures que nous ne voulons pas voir
figurer dans ce texte et nous avons
redit que s'il n'y avait pas d'évolution
la cfdt sera en capacité de se mobiliser
pas l'air très conciliant quand même
encore laurent berger qu'il connaissait
bien il attend il attend effectivement
de les avancer sur des points que je
connais notamment le barème des
indemnités près de mal le barème des
indemnités prud'homale et puis la
définition des licenciements économiques
je crois que chose de points qui sont
essentielles aujourd'hui dans le débat
alors quelles avancées pas si vous voyez
est ce que par exemple sur l'aim sur le
barème des indemnités aux prud'hommes à
est ce qu'on peut proposer par exemple
n'ont pas un plafond mais un plancher
d'indemnisation exotiques et de
réflexion je pense que je pense qu'il
avait été laissé une marge de
négociation comme toujours aux
parlementaires parce que finalement ce
texte sortant du conseil d'état envoyés
présenté au conseil des ministres va
être mis entre les mains des
parlementaires la commission des
affaires sociales de l'assemblée pour
commencer va dire peut-être le plafond
qui est mis et insuffisant quand on
regarde par rapport à l'allemagne par
exemple je crois qu'après 20 ans de
travail c'est 24 mois en allemagne ces
15 mois et qui est proposé donc on peut
corriger cela j'indique quand même que
cette barémisation était déjà dans la
loi dans la loi macron que moi j'étais
favorable mais savait essentiellement
oui pour d'autres raisons mais j'y étais
favorable si vous me permettez je veux
dire pourquoi je suis favorable une
barémisation qui peut être indicative
elle n'est peut-être pas obligatoire
elle peut être indicative pourquoi je
suis favorable
parce qu'avec ma collègue christiane
taubira on a fait le tour des
prud'hommes et il ya des situations très
différentes d'après demain un autre et
vous avez des endroits où les salariés
peuvent attendre très longtemps j'ai
entendu que la moyenne était de 18 mois
sûrement pas la région parisienne
puisque il ya encore un cas de septembre
qui n'est pas traitée entre temps
l'annoncé territoriales une inégalité
territoriale un manque d'uniformité ou
du oud uniformisation de la
jurisprudence donc et qui est un barème
de référence je pense que c'est une
bonne chose
le juge dira cerles mercklé resserre
selon vous ce serait je pense qu'il
faudrait faire comme comme en allemagne
où les patrons ne sont pas aussi
forcément satisfait par ce projet de loi
notamment la cgpme qui représente les
tpe les pme
je vous propose d'écouter françois
asselin et puis on réagit ensuite nous
avons besoin de souplesse nous avons
besoin d'être rassurés nous avons besoin
qu'en cas malheureusement de
retournements de conjoncture et bien on
puisse adapter l'entreprise à son
environnement et nous constatons avec
beaucoup de regret qu autour de
certaines annonces qui sont dans ce
texte certains articles
eh bien il ya une totale de
désinformation qui a pris une ampleur
phénoménale
ce qu'on veut tout simplement c'est que
on sache lorsqu'il faut réduire la
voilure et bien où chacun met les pieds
que ça soit du côté du salarié comme du
côté de l'employeur surtout quand c'est
une petite entreprise qui souvent est
très fragile n'a pas les capacités
financières d'un grand groupe
alors françois asselin fait allusion à
l'assouplissement du licenciement
économique est ce qu'il faudrait selon
vous dans ce texte différencier le cas
des tpe et des pme des grands groupes
oui vous savez quand on fait des
différences de ce genre on peut être
sanctionnée par le conseil
constitutionnel donc il ya à prendre
avec qu'on met toutes les cautions
non mais il y à des dispositifs qui
renvoie des accords d'entreprises de
petite entreprise d'ailleurs dans le
dans le texte qui donne plus de place
aux accords d'entreprise et faut
rappeler quand même qu' il y à chaque
année 36 milles accord d'entreprise qui
sont signés y compris d'ailleurs une
majorité par la cgt au niveau local donc
le fait qu'il y ait des accords
d'entreprise correspond je crois à
l'esprit de ce que demande de monsieur à
cela ce qui est vrai il faut donner de
la souplesse un peu plus de souplesse
aux entreprises mais en même temps il
faut pas retirer des droits aux salariés
ça c'est pas possible et donc on a
affaire cet équilibre je pense qu'il
faut revoir les conditions de définition
des licenciements économiques
quelles seraient vos propositions à vous
bien d'allonger déjà les durées de prise
en compte parce que je pense que quatre
mois c'est beaucoup trop court 4
trimestre pernod ricard c'est beaucoup
c'est beaucoup trop long pour débourser
le quoi leur sert à 5 par exemple 1 non
je pense que celle des ter d'ici ce même
je pense qu'il faut il faut revoir ça on
ne peut pas avoir de doute sur
l'interprétation sur les causes qui
amène à des licenciements économiques
donc cette redéfinition et à travailler
je pense que c'est ce qu'ils font avec
les syndicats réformistes selon vous on
peut encore trouver un compromis sur ces
deux points qui sont les deux points
qu'il fonde plus débat sur ce projet de
loi il y a le séminaire organisé ce soir
avec les partis parlementaires
socialistes
vous pensez que manuel valls peut encore
convaincre une partie de ses troupes
très hostile quand même encore au projet
de loi oui mais je crois que ces deux
points sont deux points essentiels et
que les parlementaires socialistes en
sont conscients les présidents de
groupes avec lesquels j'ai pu
m'entretenir en sont conscients et si
j'ai bien entendu hier au bureau
national
il y avait beaucoup d'expressions en ce
sens au bureau national du parti
socialiste
tout déficit donc on a on à la nécessité
de bouge il faut bouger il faut entendre
et il faut pas se braquer et dire qu'on
est droit dans ses bottes non la
négociation la concertation a lieu en ce
moment
alors justement le bureau national est
parti socialiste et hier soir et on a pu
entendre la lourde charge à nouveau de
martine aubry contre ce projet de loi je
vous propose de réentendre martine aubry
et on discute après j'ai essayé
d'expliquer derrière m comrie que la
réforme du code du travail quelle
qu'elle prévoyait une réforme ni qui
améliorent la compétitivité de
l'entreprise qui accroît la protection
des salariés
elle est extrêmement dangereuse
notamment sur le droit de licenciement
elle est dangereuse quand on substitue
des accords d'entreprise à des accords
de branche
mettons le paquet sur la formation sur
la recherche sur l'innovation
il faut que les salariés se sont bien
aussi dans l'entreprise si on souhaite
effectivement ce qu'ils y soient
attaqués et qu'ils améliorent encore
leur leur compétitivité cette loi c'est
donc une régression comme semble
entendre un ensemble de dire des
modifications à apporter
moi je note que martine aubry n'a pas
demandé le rejet du texte hier mais des
améliorations à apporter
et donc il faut apporter ces
améliorations j'ai donné deux exemples
mais je pense qu'on peut faire plus de
place c'est ce que souhaite la cfdt est
la raison aux accords d'entreprise je le
redis et donc il ya une norme on
respecte les normes
l'argumentaire comme quoi il y aura un
renversement de la hiérarchie des normes
faut pas exagérer la loi reste la loi
les accords interprofessionnels aussi
les accords de branche aussi mais il
peut y avoir des accords d'entreprise et
il peut y avoir des référendum des
salariés qui donnent leur position
mais à entendre martine aubry on a
l'impression qu'on n'est plus tellement
dans la dimension technique mais dans
l'arrière pensée politique
elle était peut-être dans l'affectif oui
plein l'affectif vous trouvez vous lis
dans sa relation avec myriam el khomri
ah c'est ça justement myriam et les
conneries quel regard vous portez sur
celle qui vous a succédé à terre c'est
très difficile de parler de quelqu'un
qui vous a succédé je me suis abstenu de
le faire j'ai parlé de merrill a même
souhaité que j'ai je ne vais pas fait ou
n'a rien dit du bien d'elle d'ailleurs
dans la pqr encore ce week end c'est une
c'est une femme courageuse qui
travaillent c'est une belle personne
elle a les épaules assez larges pour
porter un tel projet de loi dans ce
contexte politique le porte puis les
poulets pour le porter la emmanuel va
c'est ce qui joue son autorité sa
méthode sur ce projet de loi
manuel valls et c'est une c'est un
moment important pour lui il en est il
en est conscient je crois et donc il est
je trouve depuis quelques jours ouverts
à la négociation rencontre savait il a
une histoire qui est un peu commune avec
la cfdt il a toujours été proche des
syndicats réformistes et donc moi je ne
doute pas qu'ils les entendent
quand vous dites qu'ils jouent un moment
important je pense nous allons le passé
on ne sait pas ce qui va se passer
demain on voit qu'il y a heureusement
maintenant des camps économistes qui à
nouveau prennent la parole pour dire ce
texte c'est pas l'un famille qu on croit
entendre tirage des gens oui ou non
philippe à lyon ce matin
donc voilà c'est des économistes qui
sont des les gens tout à fait connu et
reconnu
et si a été ma surprise c'est quand même
que des gens qui ne connaissaient pas le
texte encore au départ est tout de suite
crier au loup
vous pensez à qui personne à personne
en fait une certaine tribune qui a été
publiée par exemple non parce que je
pense convaincre qu'ils sont renseignés
mais je pense que c'est parti très vite
et beaucoup de gens ont dit de venir que
le gouvernement a perdu la bataille de
la communication alors je pense que je
pense que la communication était mieux
les dix ont mal engagée et que c'est une
des raison première de difficultés que
rencontre ce texte laissait penser je
voudrais dire une fois de laisser penser
que ce texte ne pourrait passer entre
guillemets qu'avec le 49-3 parce que
c'est ça que les gens ont compris ça
faisait peser sur ce test une certaine
suspicion dont la communication est mal
engagée ce que c'est rattrapable
mais oui se rattrapa par la concertation
se rattrapa par l' écoute et c'est
rattrapable par des modifications
malgré la mobilisation de demain et
manille ont fait la grève voire faux
faux pas mais faut pas tout mélanger
vous le savez non les quinze jours qui
viennent voir si en avance je pense que
il faut qu'il y ait des avancées
significatives et que dans les
propositions des syndicats réformistes
soient prises en compte pourquoi pas
parce qu'on avait déjà beaucoup de
choses on a fait beaucoup de choses et
moi ce que je constate c'est que
malheureusement on ne s'est jamais
arrêtée pour dire ce qu'on fait et ça
c'est un des reproches majeurs que je
fais à l'histoire de ce quinquennat
c'est ne jamais avoir valorisé ce qui
avait été dit de ne pas avoir dès le
départ on s'est un peu plus original les
cinémas d'expression de ce quinquennat
ne pas avoir dit quelle était la
situation de ne pas avoir dit qu'est ce
qu'on allait faire
d'avoir eu peut-être une vision un peu
optimiste des choses il faut le faut le
reconnaître
françois hollande tous a commenté l'ex
flic de france politique non non je la
situation n'est pas facile
elle n'était pas facile quand on est
arrivé tout de suite il ya eu délit des
plans de licenciements qui avait été
repoussée je peux penser à peugeot à psa
mois les reçus ici en tant que président
de groupe et patron du groupe uni il
s'en sort maintenant il a fallu quatre
ans pour que le groupe ressort des
bénéfices c'était très important
donc voila et puis les choses de faites
des avancées ce jeu les dix la bouche du
réel c'est à dire celles qui gouvernent
en ce moment elle a créé des nouveaux
droits et mais simplement elle les a pas
meilleure valeur encore la prime
d'activité l'autre jour je regardais on
croirait que c'est là la caf qui
distribue ça comme ça par décision de la
caf très bien la caisse d'allocations
familiales fait très belles choses mais
c'est une décision qui était d'ailleurs
norma loy et qui a été mise en oeuvre au
1er janvier
on peut parler d des retraites après les
carrières longues
on peut parler aussi du droit à la
formation personne n'a parlé vraiment ce
droit à la formation
et puis du compte personnel d'activité
qui est une grande avancée qui est dans
le texte et qui devrait encore renforcer
donc je comprends ma question est ce que
c'est un peu la faute quand même de
françois hollande qui n'a pas su mettre
en valeur ce bilan la qui n'a pas
supporté
peut-être on n'a pas su aussi
d'expliquer peut-être le parc on a
toujours dit qu'il manquait toujours une
ligne économique socialiste
n'at-il pas non plus fait le travail
d'explication qui était nécessaire
peut-être n'at-on pas pris le temps je
me mets dedans n'at-on pas pris le temps
de faire la pause de l'explication
donc on enchaîne les réformes les unes
après les autres
mais si on s'arrête pas un moment pour
dire voilà ce qui était fait mal et
français il ne sache pas ils le
connaissent ils le savent pas voilà ça
leur donne l'impression que tout n'a pas
été tenté contre le chômage
oui même si je le pense j'avais dit que
l'année 2015 serait meilleure que
l'année 2014 vous en rappelez il y a
aujourd'hui au sens du bit et moi de 3
millions de chômeurs dans en france
voilà au sens du bit le million huit
cent soixante deux millions huit cent
soixante mille selon les chiffres du pib
mais combien de chômeurs en plus depuis
qu'un canal françois hollande
si on prend les chiffres du bit et on
n'arrive pas vous savez
vous permettez de minutes d'explications
il ya il ya trois ans une minute il ya
trois ans les chiffres de pôle emploi et
les chiffres du bit et du bureau
international du travail était identique
à 100 milles près il y avait 2 millions
neuf cent mille chômeurs recensés par
les deux aujourd'hui il y en a 2
millions 900 mille recensés par le bit
et y en a trois millions cinq cent mille
recensés par pôle emploi
cherchez l'erreur votre explication à
vous mon explication c'est que pôle
emploi de son départ un outil
statistique très bien et bien on
travaillera sur pôle emploi alors sans
cette semaine on va parler fait à la
deuxième partie de cette émission avec
un parti socialiste de plus en plus
divisés des ambitions qui s'expriment
aussi de plus en plus ouvertement je
pense par exemple dernièrement à
emmanuel macron une primaire à gauche
qui se dessine
on va aborder tout de suite les
questions avec stéphanie le rouge
journalistes dans notre partenaire l'
agence france-presse
autour de cette question le ps peut-il
mourir mais avant d'accueillir se manie
le rouge que pèse exactement manuel
valls au sein du parti socialiste
alors selon la députée karine berger qui
était l'invité ce matin de notre
matinale
et bien il ne pèse pas plus que seront
score de la primaire en 2011 en
l'écoutant à gauche de manuel valls hier
soir au bureau national c'était moins de
5% du bureau national donc s'il ya
irréconciliables it2
de gauche y en a une qui fait 5 % et
l'autre qui fait 95%
donc non moi je ne crois pas la fracture
irrémédiable de la gauche pense que le
parti socialiste est l'endroit où les de
gauche historique en tout cas ont
toujours cohabité mais qu' il faut pas
pousser le bouchon trop loin et que il y
à un certain nombre de positions qui ne
sont plus des positions gauche quand on
donne un permis de licenciés à des
multinationales dans un texte de loi on
est on est en train de sortir du champ
de la gauche bonsoir stéphane est alors
le parti socialiste peut il mourir votre
cv votre question à françois rebsamen
oui bonsoir monsieur rebsamen on a
commencé à l'évoquer tout à l'heure
martine aubry a publié il ya moins de 15
jours une tribune au vitriol est
désormais les les opposants à la
politique du gouvernement sont
majoritaires au bureau national du ps
est ce que vous pensez qu'il ya un
risque de scission d'explosion de ce
parti comme on a pu l'entendre je me
suis posé la question et j'ai d'ailleurs
fait une tribune sur ce sujet je pense
qu'il y a effectivement mais c'est pas
nouveau dans l'histoire du parti
socialiste il y a de gauche y en a une
qui est plutôt j'allais dire sociale
libérale et puis une autre qui est
plutôt la gauche traditionnelle que l'on
connaît du parti socialiste il ya un axe
central qui a toujours permis de
réconcilier ces deux gauches pour faire
ce qu'on appelle la synthèse entre les
deux est-ce que l'écart c'est le sens de
votre question aujourd'hui est telle que
ces deux gauches sont irréconciliables
je ne le crois pas je ne le crois pas et
j'ai eu le sentiment hier
bien sûr si je mets à part quelqu'un qui
est peut-être un peu spécifique dans le
parti socialiste comme gérard filoche
mais si on met à part gérard filoche et
bien j'ai eu l'impression que tout le
monde était pour avancer pour qu'il n'y
ait pas non pas un retrait du texte mais
une amélioration du test nous parlons du
texte sur le travail et donc je pense
que c'est de gauche ne sont pas
irréconciliables et moi je souhaite vous
je sois monsieur le premier ministre
manuel valls a dit
lui a parlé de deux gauches
irréconciliables justement donc vous
inscrivez en faut il penser de la pensée
plutôt à la gauche de jean luc mélenchon
ou effectivement la rupture là et
consommer d'ailleurs on a mené
différence aujourd'hui entre jean luc
mélenchon et les frondeurs des parties
sociales et une grande différence c'est
que ces gens semblent au bureau national
du parti socialiste en échange on a des
débats on avance ensemble et il ya des
interventions qui sont faites par
certains frondeurs qui sont de qualité
qui permet bien entre manuel valls et
les frondeurs mais il ya le débat il ya
l'amélioration il s'est dit décidée de
linguee mais c'est ce sont deux lignes
qui sont différentes mais qui cohabitent
au sein du parti socialiste et quand
souvent cohabiter on pourrait dire
rocard je cherche rocard chevènement et
avec mitterrand qui faisait là c'est ce
que manuel valls joue pas un peu sa
propre partition malgré tout face à
hollande qui doit rassembler la gauche
le plus possible manuel valls poursuit
son sillon de réformistes et peut-être
au risque de se couper de d'une partie
la gauche oui 7,7 un réformiste mais moi
je pense que c'est un réformiste de
gauche et donc il doit rester un
réformiste de gauche et le réformisme de
gauche c'est une part essentielle du
parti socialiste vous voyez pas une
feuille de papier entre pas dit ça il ya
des différences il y a des
il ya des divergences il ya des
différences je pense qu'elles ne sont
pas irréconciliables elle tient à quoi
elles tiennent peut-être à des à des
postures personnel une analyse
différente de la société je pense que le
premier ministre est aujourd'hui
convaincu que la société attend de
l'autorité je crois qu'il l'a carmes
bien et je pense que une autre partie
delà de la gauche du parti socialiste
à l'intérieur du parti socialiste pense
que c'est la question sociale qui est
primordial et donc moi je pense que ce
n'est pas contradictoire je voudrais le
dire ici il faut qu'il y ait de
l'autorité parce qu'il faut donner de la
protéger et assurer la sécurité la
sûreté
nos concitoyens surtout dans des
périodes troublées comme elles sont
aujourd'hui et puis en même temps alors
ça c'est peut-être un peu ma
particularité
je pense qu'il faut prendre en compte la
question sociale la question sociale
le modèle social français c'est quelque
chose dont on doit se préoccuper je suis
très heureux de voir que le manuel valls
mène aujourd'hui les consultations les
concertations et les négociations j'en
ai mené avec lui d'ailleurs quand
j'étais est d'ailleurs le texte que j'ai
présentées il a été adopté par la gauche
il n'a pas été adopté par le 49-3 alors
justement sur ce climat à gauche et sur
le couple exécutif je vous propose
d'écouter le sénateur une carbonade un
proche de manuel valls
voilà simplement un président un premier
ministre qui depuis le début de ce
quinquennat on vit de la russie du pis
on n'est pas en train de parler deux
destins personnels ou de carrière
personnelle on voit bien que c'est un
jeu collectif qui doit nous emmener vers
l'élection présidentielle qui va être
difficile il faut le reconnaître parce
qu'il ya de fortes interrogations chez
nos concitoyens est en tous les cas on
aura besoin des maires des
parlementaires pour qu'ils soient des
relais oui vous pensez qu'il n'y a pas
de divergence entre françois hollande et
manuel valls comme l'a dit monsieur
carvena ce dont je pense que les
arbitrages sont rendus en commun oui oui
je le pense
président de la république est dans son
rôle pourrait même ministres aussi non
je pense que les choses se font en
commun
rien de ce qui se fait dans ce pays
n'est l'étranger au président de la
république en matière de décision donc
voilà après le le premier ministre il a
aussi son tempérament il met les choses
en ordre
à sa manière donc ça c'est sûr il ya des
différences de tempérament tandis que
manuel valls a tendance à hystériser le
le débat ce qui n'est pas forcément la
meilleure chose dans la perspective de
2017 du rassemblement de la gauche
est-ce que vous pensez que françois
hollande sera en mesure de rassembler la
gauche pour être candidat en 2017 je le
souhaite je l'espère malgré ce qu'il
soit fâché d'une part avec la gauche
sociétale sur la déchéance et maintenant
avec la gauche sociale autour du texte
au sénat françois hollande c'est le
président de la république sortant
c'est le point d'équilibré de la gauche
je le pensais je pense que ce sera ce
serait c'est lui qui prendra cette
décision bien sûr le meilleur candidat
pour nous celui qui est capable de
rassembler voilà donc le parti
socialiste finalement est condamné à la
synthèse hollande est oui c'est vous
savez elle je veux pas parler de
m'interroger sur partie société je vien
répondre
il est effectivement il peut il peut
mourir le parti socialiste effectivement
il peut exploser le parti socialiste
peut y avoir des fractures et rennais
diable il ya déjà eu quelques départs ça
arrivait dans son histoire
la question qu'on se pose souvent parti
socialiste c'est est ce que le cycle
d'epinay est terminée et donc à chaque
fois qu'il ya un problème la question
revient sur la table il y en a qui
brandit sa et qui dit le cycle d'epinay
terminait plus les parties sammer ça se
transforme ça serait génère on le voit à
droite aussi à gauche c'est pareil
par contre je suis sûr d'une chose c'est
que la gauche elle ne mourra pas et ceux
qui de temps en temps s'exprime
maintenant la gauche peut mourir non la
gauche la dengue et le parisien c'est
une erreur le parti socialiste oui mais
moi le premier secrétaire jean
christophe cambadélis avait lancé cette
idée d'alliance populaire justement pour
renouveler le parti ça a pas l'air de
très bien fonctionner est-ce que la
primaire pour la présidentielle ça
pourrait être un autre moyen de faire ce
que les gauches parle à nouveau de
grandes maisons
jean christophe cambadélis projet assez
dubitatif non je suis dubitatif parce
que il faut il faut que tout le monde
soit soit d'accord pour participer à
cela
donc il faut donc s'y lie à une primaire
bon il faut que à la sortie de la
primaire il ya un seul candidat ce
serait d'ailleurs une bonne chose
après est ce que le président de la
république s'il est candidat on met
beaucoup de si l'un est ce qu'il a envie
de se plier à cette primaire je n'en
sais rien ça peut être une bonne
occasion s'il y a à la sortie qu'un seul
candidat
mais c'est pas facile de faire une
primaire en étant président de la
république vous en conviendrez surtout
une situation difficile qu'on connaît
que le connaît le pays aujourd'hui
c'est pourtant ce que certains
souhaitant notamment ici au sénat je
vous propose d'écouter marie noëlle
lienemann la sénatrice elle voudrait une
primaire qui ré jusqu'à françois
hollande
en l'écoutant il voue au devant des
primaires pourquoi parce qu'il faut
qu'au moment des primaires s'incarne des
personnes et des propositions peut pas
séparer l'un et l'autre et là les
électeurs qui seront aux primaires
pourront choisir moi j'ai caché à
personne que j'étais prêt à être
candidate et que je serai candidate si
des primaires mais pour moi la priorité
c'est un qu'il y à des primaires 2
vous savez je me méfie de ces
incarnations personnel la vème
république nous fait croire cela quel
est le camp aujourd'hui qui à l'homme
providentiel personnes voient la marina
l'ennemane qui était interrogé au salon
de l'agriculture c'est pour ça qu'on
entend un petit coq au début donc une
famille une bonne partie du ps les
frondeurs la motion b de karine berger
se sont prononcés pour pour la primaire
mais aussi le brochet d'une primaire je
pense une primaire de toute la gauche
j'ai repris la formule donc des macros
un mélange oui je pense que c'était une
bonne idée
il faut que tout le monde ait la volonté
quand on fait une primaire de débattre
et d'accepter les résultats de cette
primaire sans passer par la case
hollande
si le président est candidat il dira
s'il se plie ou pas la primaire la
primaire c'est aussi l'occasion de
d'affronter ou de confronter plus
exactement des lignes politiques et
c'est pour ça que marie noëlle lienemann
disais cela elles représentent une
partie
de l'histoire du parti socialiste est-ce
que la participation de monsieur
mélenchon est indispensable parce que on
a pu avoir l'impression que
en faire un préalable était une manière
de dire non à la primaire en fait donc
est ce que vous vous dites oui pourquoi
pas une primaire y compris sans mélange
chimique en baissant mélenchon je vous
dis compris sur mélenchon mais c'est
vrai que l'idée était quand même d'avoir
un résultat qui qui couvrent tout le
champ de la gauche et de la gauche de la
gauche mais avec mélenchon c'est
extrêmement compliqué vous le savez
peut-être un proche depuis longtemps de
françois hollande france à metz queuleu
continuer à le voir régulièrement
beaucoup s'interrogent dans son
entourage je le vois veut s qui pourrait
être candidat en 2017
je me tiens on n'a pas parlé pour lui il
en parle à personne je crois pas en tout
le cas ils ne peuvent pas moi pas moi je
le vois quand je demande à le voir sans
trop de difficulté mais de ça nous
n'avons pas encore parlé
donc on sent beaucoup d'interrogations
dans son entourage certains semble un
petit peu perdues sur sa stratégie est
ce que c'est également votre cas non moi
je pense que le moment venu il fera
connaître son choix
toute façon il peut pas le faire
maintenant puisqu'il a pris moi je crois
à la parole présidentielle
il a dit que sa candidature était liée à
la version de la courbe du chômage et
donc vraiment gagner parce que je le
crois alors après qu'elle ait lequel est
l'outil de référence
c'est pour ça que j'ai parlé du
bénévolat j'ai bien compris il a l'air
plus que des statistiques de pôle emploi
mais de toute façon à terme si le
chômage diminue ça se verra aussi dans
les statistiques de pôle emploi
et jusqu'à quand peut-il attendre avant
de se déclarer on a pu entendre qu' il
pourrait
faire savoir qu'il n'est pas candidat si
vous n'allez pas en octobre après ça
dépend vous savez il ya des stratégies
différentes apprécié à le dire ce
presque de la tactique c'est de la
stratégie en réalité nous avons aidé les
présidents sortants qui sont présentés
au dernier moment françois mitterrand en
mars autant que je me rappelle 88 ou
quelque chose comme ça donc il y avait
attendu le dernier moment
d'autres qui prennent un peu plus
d'avancé pour le faire donc on verra il
ya la primaire de la droite à la rentrée
prochaine ça doit être au mois de
novembre
donc c'est important aussi de voir ce
que font les adversaires
donc parce que là franchement maintenant
dans cette tripartite isation de la
société politique du débat politique
c'est l'essentiel c'est quand même
aujourd'hui devant la droite donc de
rassembler la gauche à se rassembler la
gauche
on parle d'une candidature de
d'arnaud montebourg
vous pensez que ce serait
une bonne idée destructeur moi moi ceci
s'il ya une primaire et carnot se mettre
dans la primaire très bien il a déjà
fait une fois voilà il peut le faire une
deuxième
si les candidats semblent avoir imprimé
pas non plus les primaires le seul
intérêt de la primaire c'est d'avoir un
seul candidat après des fois on a des
surprises on peut faire 5 % est le
premier ministre il ya d'autres
ambitions aussi qui semble se préciser
je pense à emmanuel macron ils se
préparent ils s'en cachent même plus
vraiment il a dit ce matin sur france
inter
j'ai envie de faire plus pour le pays il
va sortir aussi bientôt de livres il
pourrait être un candidat en 2017 merial
macro moi je pourrais m'en temps du
parti je ne sais pas je n'imagine pas
cela il est prêt et effectivement il est
pur parti socialiste moi ce que je
souhaite c'est qui consacre tout son
temps et toute son énergie à travailler
pour faire réussir ce gouvernement
l'avenir c'est le garçon intéressant
intelligent
oui oui j'espère pour nous pour la
gauche il a des convictions c'est un
homme de gauche je le crois sincèrement
même si il est un peu trop libérale
avant goût sur l'économie s'il pourrait
se lancer dans cette course à la
présidence à l'homo je lui conseille de
travailler en tant que ministre de
l'économie dans ses fonctions
ministérielles et voulu conseillé d'être
élu aussi avant je lui avais proposé
au tout début je vais proposer de venir
alors on dit c'est pour ça que j'ai vu
ressortir que je soutenais un fax de
proposer j'avais dit si tu cherches une
circonscription en bourgogne il peut y
en avoir une
il m'avait dit que ça ne veut pas
l'intéressé
comprenez que ça puisse même pas
l'intéressé j'ai pas le même parcours
vous qui avez un parcours totalement
dites moi j'ai un parcours
voici une autre façon de faire la
politique c'est sa dignité j'ai un
parcours météorique moi je crois que le
suffrage universel c'est quand même ce
qui confère la légitimité
voilà donc je pense qu'il faut et élus
mais bon après tout s'il est prêt lui
raymond barre n'était pas élu il a été
premier ministre
on peut on peut avoir on peut avoir une
activité politique
on peut avoir même un cursus politique
sans être élu semble-t-il il sort si
vous voulez sur l'air du temps en disant
qu'il est parti c'est un peu dépassé est
ce que ces points de vue ce qu'on disait
ils ont besoin autour du parti
socialiste pas folle et c'est vrai qu'il
faudrait dépasser un peu tout ça c'est
vrai qu'il faudrait une nouvelle maison
commune c'est vrai qu'il faut ouvrir les
portes et les fenêtres mais j'ai déjà
entendu ça tellement de fois que vous
n'y croyez pas si mais je me dis qu'il
faut reprendre sans arrêt le métier
l'ouvragé recommencer donc on va le
faire pour autant je crois vraiment que
l'onction excusez moi du suffrage
universel c'est quelque chose
d'important très bien m'a écouté merci
beaucoup
stéphanie on va passer la troisième
partie de cette émission avec un manuel
valls donc non seulement un peu empêtré
en ce moment dans cette réforme autour
de la loi travail mais également encore
et toujours en première ligne sur la
révision constitutionnelle et la fameuse
déchéance de nationalité
examiné en séance par le sénat la
semaine prochaine
le premier ministre était auditionné ce
matin par la commission des lois du
sénat
il a bien sûr beaucoup étaient
interrogés sur la déchéance de
nationalité et les risques d'apatridie
on écoute manuel valls
l'article 25 du code civil fait aussi
une distinction pour prononcer la
déchéance de la nationalité
entre ceux qui disposent d'une autre
nationalité et ceux qui n'en disposent
pas seuls les premiers pourront faire
l'objet de cette sanction pallier ces
manques de notre droit c'est le sens de
la rédaction de l'article 2 que le
gouvernement propose je sais c'est
normal qu'elle suscite des
interrogations en raison du risque
d'apatridie qui sera en conséquence
encourus et nous sommes d'ailleurs
depuis le début confronté à cette
question le débat sur cet article
intériste comme on dit le gouvernement
qui avait respecté l'avis du conseil
d'état a fait évoluer son projet de
constitutionnel pour en tenir compte
nous avons fait évoluer avec l'accord du
président de la république pour tenir
compte des débats
je le dis à ceux qui maintenant voudrait
sacralisé la parole du président la
république à l'occasion du 2e congrès
parce que la constitution et notre texte
suprême parce qu'elle a une force
solennel le gouvernement s'est rallié à
une écriture qui ne distinguera aucune
catégorie de français par rapport à une
autre
voilà mickaël szames s de public sénat
nous a rejoints par trois avec cette
question je l'annonçais tout à l'heure
est ce que si vous étiez encore
parlementaires sénateurs vous voteriez
cette révision constitutionnelle est bon
d'aller poser tout de suite la guerre
est ce que vous vous soyez il faut que
je donne une explication avant de donner
de répondre à cette question et je le
ferai
premièrement je n'étais pas très chaud
pour la déchéance de nationalité
j'aurais préféré l'indignité nationale
je le dis mais après tout à partir du
moment où ça a été présenté par le
président de la république que envisagé
par le président de la république devant
le congrès unanime
debout à l'applaudir je me dis que ce
n'est pas rien ce qui m'a le plus
surpris c'est de voir que des gens qui
ne s'était pas préoccupé de ce sujet
avant les attentats et avant la
déclaration du président de la
république n'avait jamais signifié
contesté le fait que la france n'ait
jamais ratifié la convention de 61 et
qu'elle ne l'est que signé mais je me
suis dit c'est quand même étonnant que
ceux qui sont contre la déchéance
pendant tant d'années
il n'est jamais demandé à ce que la
france ratifié la convention de 61 vous
savez la convention de 61 l'actualité
c'est qu'on a beaucoup plus parlé bien
sûr mais elle a été signée avec une
clause qui permettait l'apatridie pour
scott pour il y avait atteinte grave à
l'état donc cette clause elle a été mise
en scène réserve qui a été fait par la
france elle est là depuis 61
elle est pas de la constitution non mais
elle est là puis 61 c'est vrai mais elle
est pas dans la constitution vrai donc
le débat a rejailli mois à partir du
moment où je les dis le président
république a pris cet engagement moi
j'ai souscrit mais j'ai fait une
remarque une deuxième remarque il peut
pas y avoir de différence entre les
français
donc je pense que oui bi nationaux
doivent être sortis de cela et pourquoi
pas parce que il peut pas y avoir d'un
côté des français entièrement à part et
de l'autre des français à part il peut
pas y avoir non plus d'apatrides
contentant manuel valls à l'instant il
va y avoir des apatrides
visiblement même moi je suis pour que le
texte je le dis ici je suis au sénat je
vous connaissez la mairie boîte conseils
à donner
avec ses terrasses je trouve que la
formule de manuel valls tout à l'heure
était plutôt joli désacraliser le disque
automates voilà ça c'est quand même
c'est vrai que ça sera à fronts
renversés de voir le sénat aujourd'hui
sacralisé d'une certaine manière
l'engagement du président de la
république moi je pense que le travail
qui a été fait à l'assemblée nationale
est un beau travail et donc je pense que
cette affaire a assez duré et je pense
que le sénat devrait aujourd'hui validé
la proposition qui est transmise par
l'assemblée nationale a voté conforme
je vous dis je oui je pense qu'on en a
assez il y en a assez
alors que s'en sortir par le haut oui
votre confort oui je pense qu'il
faudrait à votre confort faudra aller
vite
je pense que les français sont lassés de
ce débat parce que tout le monde sait
qu'il ya beaucoup de symbolique c'est
très important
beaucoup de symbolique derrière ça mais
peu d'efficacité et finalement ça
n'appelle que vous lancez à la droite
aujourd'hui monsieur oui je voudrais
dire écoutez on arrête
et sinon si c'est pour répartir pendant
des mois moi je lui tire opposants de la
république nommé coûtera peut-être pas
il faut retirer ça une fois les
sénatoriales gouvernement aujourd'hui
parce que là le sens des responsabilités
et françois rebsamen c'est à dire que si
jamais on voté conforme aujourd'hui on
ira un congrès à versailles
moi je pense oui je pense que j'ai si
c'est pas le cas il n'y aura pas de
congrès je ne sais pas ça dépend pas de
moi maintenant je vous ai dit qu'elle
était ma position d'autant bien vous
seriez parlementaire aujourd'hui vous
voteriez conforme le texte connu
moi oui moi oui j'ai j'avais fait mes
remarques avant j'aurais préféré la
dignité mais j'expliquais voulait
l'union nationale c'était le serment de
versailles comme dit manuel valls
il récolte les critiques de votre gauche
des critiques de la droite c'est échec
sur toute la ligne
ça n'a pas duré longtemps ce que ce
sentiment d'union nationale et je le
regrette profondément
il ya eu quelqu'un ici un sénateur que
je respecte
ainsi un premier ministre qui a fait des
déclarations je parle de jean pierre
raffarin que j'ai trouvé tout à fait
estimable qui t'engueulent m à cet
instant oui je le pense
mais la vie politique a repris le débat
politique aux politiciens a repris trop
vite le dessus
moi je pense sincèrement que dans la
période qu'on a connu je l' ai même dit
un gouvernement moi vous voyez jusqu'où
jallet un gouvernement d'union nationale
correspondait à l'état d'urgence que
nous auriez voulu sur le moment pour le
moment sur le moment les nations après
après mais personne n'en veut et
personne n'a répondu ni dans un sens ni
dans un autre parti national parti
politique ce sont repartis dans leurs
débats l'affrontement gauche droite a
repris un an et mon vieux clivages à un
an de la présidentielle c'est peut-être
comme ça que ça se passe
ce mode de scrutin génère cela donc
c'est tout ça qu'il faut revoir à dijon
oui mais de dix jours est-ce qu'on vous
parle de ce texte très sincèrement on en
a beaucoup parlé au mois de décembre
pour après les voeux du président
puisqu'il avait évoqué cela dans ses
voeux depuis on m'en parle plus dans nos
moments par le coup de tactique
politicienne entre la droite et la
gauche parce que ça intéresse vraiment
les français vous qui est en prise avec
les français
écoutez je vois des dijonnais se défend
c'est tous les jours j'ai rencontre des
associations je rencontre beaucoup de
monde
personne ne m'interpelle en disant faut
aller
il faut avancer sur le la déchéance de
nationalité est sur le retour de la
réforme du conseil supérieur de la
magistrature lors de l'audition devant
la commission des lois du sénat ce matin
le garde des sceaux a précisé que le
texte serait examiné le 6 avril c'est
bien ce texte pour rassurer notamment
les magistrats comme ils sont inquiets
des nouvelles prérogatives
je pense bien je m'en souviens ce qu'a
fait jean jacques urvoas en fait le
nouveau garde des sceaux
oui je pense c'est bien et là vous
pensez qu'il y aura une majorité au jeu
je crois je voter cette réforme du
conseil stratus je pense vraiment quand
même que au moment où on voit des
menaces n'ont pas disparu et où il doit
y avoir un esprit de responsabilité qui
doit s'imprimer ici au sénat également
il est là déjà par essence au sénat on
le sait mais il faut l'ont peut-être que
renforcer un peu alors on va parler
d'autres dossiers qui sont un peu
allégés un kiff achats au sein du
gouvernement notamment le nucléaire il
ya eu cette cacophonie
ces derniers jours le nucléaire français
critiquée aussi par nos voisins
européens
alors nos centrales serait à bout de
souffle et la promesse de françois
hollande de fermer fessenheim d'ici à
2017 n'est pas certaine je vous propose
d'écouter la réaction de ségolène royal
moi je voudrais quand même dire aux
français qui nous écoutent que fermer un
réacteur où une centrale nucléaire s'est
pas tourné un robinet dans une centrale
nucléaire il ya deux shows deux
conditions pour qu'elle s'arrête
définitivement
d'une part il y a les éléments de sûreté
nucléaire et la deuxième condition ça
c'est moi qui lui donne la seconde
condition à ceux qui me demandent de
fermer du jour au lendemain une centrale
nucléaire une centrale nucléaire
professional ces deux mille emplois ces
deux mille personnes certaines 2000
s'alarmer langage à l'engagement au
numéro 41 de françois hollande et de
fermer ce sont prenables cette promesse
va-t-elle être tenus mais il ya la tenue
je ne vous donc à la promesse tenue et
si un autre temps et manuel costa
ministre du logement je dis bien du
logement
ministre de l'écologie mme faut que ça
soit fermé en 2016 et ségolène royal dit
on verra mais nos centrales sont en
bonne santé
sincèrement on comprend mieux la
décision elle est simple elle a été plus
par l'engagement par l'engagement qu'a
fait le président de la république
la centrale de fessenheim elle doit
fermer donc après il ya des conditions
de ce que dit ségolène royal est juste
et les conditions de sécurité en ferme
pas ça comme ça du jour au lendemain 10
et par où l'engagement l'engagement est
pris de fermer la centrale de fessenheim
l'udc en rade au mieux cette agression
oui mais oui comme vous le dites ça va
prendre du temps mais oui ça va prendre
du temps mais peut-être ça sera 2010 est
peut-être ce sera 2018 après il ya les
cui mais après il ya les conditions de
sécurité qui sont primordiales en la
matière c'est une des anciennes les plus
anciennes centrales françaises et donc
je pense que l'engagement doit être
respectée ces 900 mégawatts autant que
je m'en rappelle donc il faut faire des
efforts mais il faut faire des efforts
sur les ailes que les économies
alternatives aux armes en compte la
minute du logement je me répète
emmanuelle cosse dit il faut que la
ferme en 2007 ministre du logement
elle est dans son rôle de parent elle
veut dire elle je pense qu'elle veut
dire c'est une jeune ministre il faut
faut lui pardonner mais je pense qu'elle
veut dire que la décision doit être
annoncée officiellement en 2016 au plus
tard jeanne ministre ou alors elle est
sortie de son rôle de ministre est alors
oui mais je veux plus je veux pas je
veux pas la critique les jeux pas la
critiquer mais c'est pas je crois que
ségolène royal a bien dit les choses
ouais en isolement ils nous demandent de
fermer fessenheim les suisses portent
plainte contre nous sur une autre
centrale du bugey et le luxembourg s'y
met aussi
et puis l'aurait raison contre tout le
monde et puis pendant ce temps là quand
même les anglais nous propose que vous
n'avez pas d'idée construire une
nouvelle centrale ou dans les autres
pays européens prennent ou qui sont
frontaliers unis disent c'est dangereux
faut tout faire mais on va à d'autres
raisons on va attendre on a nous je
crois une autorité de sûreté nucléaire
qui est de qualité qui travaille dans la
transparence et donc la plus ancienne
c'est fessenheim l'engagement est épris
de la fermer elle sera fermée pour les
restes pour le reste moi je fais
confiance à l'autorité de sûreté
nucléaire et de la transparence
après pour pour qu'elle soit fermée 900
mégawatts je pense qu'il faut que
flamanville entrants
en invité c'est une nouvelle génération
on va voir ce qu'elle donne veut père
pour ceux qui vivent sur ces mêmes gens
passent en place et aujourd'hui qui est
lui ministre charge 182 charge de la
réforme de taille il doute lui aussi le
pack qu'on avait fait avec les verts en
2012 françois hollande avait doute de
quoi est il doute que il doute que le ps
puisse fonctionner avec bon je sais pas
j'ai mangé pas les éléments
scientifiques pour répondre à une
question
l'anglerre aussi on fait de la politique
le pacte qui avait été mis en 2012 il a
volé en éclats lui aussi non il n'a pas
volé en éclats c'est les verts qu'on
volé en éclats donc n'existe plus les
verts ballon je crois qu'il y en a plein
qui sont partis je serai en 2017 dirais
pas besoin d'eux des écologistes oui
j'ai collé derrière la la le parti vert
europe ecologie les verts c'était ça a
explosé tout le monde l'a vu mais le
mouvement écologique les écrits
mutuellement non non les écologistes
servent à une partie importante de la
gauche et je pense que les idées qu'ils
défendent qui se sont imposés bien ce
sont des idées qui sucre est novatrice
pour notre société donc le problème a
été bien évoquer bien traité je crois à
travers la coque 21 ans maintenant il
faut avancer ensemble
je parle avec l'air ça va suffire il ya
aussi le dossier notre dame des landes
oui le sien et notre dame des landes
proposition qui a été faite par le
président de la république satisfait
personne le référendum pas pourquoi
quand on le met hors logement finalement
c'est quand même le mieux c'est
finalement l'atlantique les autres dit
ça ne marchera pas menacer monde
enterrait de léser sont déjà les camps
les gens de loire-atlantique les départs
et avance conditions des collectivités
territoriales la france a été épinglée
par ce qu'on appelle le conseil de
l'europe sur la réforme des
collectivités territoriales déplore
l'absence de consultation avant cette
réforme on se fait donc épinglé par
l'europe conscience de tout ça oui oui
c'est à dire l'absence de consultation
avec les collectivités locales
oui c'est ça en amont bon je pense que
il y avait des engagements qui avaient
été pris par les uns et par les autres
par nicolas sarkozy ou à hauteur de 10
milliards d'euros par françois hollande
à hauteur de 11 milliards d'euros donc
ces engagements ont été pris devant les
français
il faut bien que les collectivités
locales participent à l'effort mais pas
trop voilà on attend on a atteint le
niveau on atteint le niveau là et on va
écouter la réaction du ministre des
collectivités à votre micro tout à
l'heure mais quel genre jean michel
baylet a on me dit que le sonore n'est
pas prêt pardon mutuel
moi si je reviens petit peu sur les
multis vite et si on parle de dijon par
exemple vous aviez dû à l'époque phare
ce qu'on appelle des emprunts toxiques
avec 3 3 ça représente 18 % de
l'ensemble des encours de là pour
expliquer aux gens c'est qu'on emprunte
un petit peu d'argent sur aujourd'hui
sur les cours de bourse pour essayer de
récupérer évidemment pour financer un
petit peu la cour des comptes de
l'époque nous encourager à prendre ce
type d'emprunt oui finalement
aujourd'hui comment ça se passe pour
vous ma brailoiu prendre un exemple très
simple et un enfant qui s'appelle
helvétique c'est assez connu le taux
d'intérêt de 0 24%
de 2008 à 2010 8 pendant dix ans il
sécurisé c'est-à-dire que la ville gagne
beaucoup d'argent puisque avec un taux
de 0 24 depuis 2008 jusqu'en 2018 on
gagne de l'argent à partir de 2018
personne ne peut dire quel sera le taux
de cet emprunt ne savez pas si vous
ignorez si vous donc j'ai décidé de
profiter des propositions qui sont
faites chez moi pour profiter de saisir
les propositions qui sont faites par le
gouvernement et d'avoir recours au fonds
de soutien pour sortir de cet emprunt
voilà encore où vous avez connu aussi
des dotations des collectivités
certainement beaucoup d'argent au moins
oui mais jamais des gens est durement
frappée oui durement frappé durement
fera comment est ce que l'on fait quand
on a été ministre quand on a été
sénateur on sait qu'on peut peser
souvent sur des décisions d'aujourd'hui
vous n'êtes plus mini sommet fut
sénateur
non mais je gardais quand même une
capacité je crois de de peser et je vais
rencontrer françois baroin jeu j'ai vu
andré laignel et j'avance des
propositions je pense que si on veut pas
à porter atteinte à l'investissement
public il faut qu'ils
un effort de l'état il vient de le faire
et 1 milliard qui a été mis en place
pour doter l'état et donc on va vous
entendre sur cette question oui bien sûr
bien sûr on va m'entendre
vous pourriez prendre une part active
dans l'association des maires de france
par exemple est urgent était vice
président de l'association
mais là aujourd'hui pour enrayer envie
d'y revenir non mais vous verrez je
prendre des responsabilités
non non non non non non jamais votre
commentaire c'est fini oui ma vie
parlementaire a fini de vous savez que
c'est interdit de cumuler donc oui voilà
sauf j'ai le jeu l'avenir que j'avais
jamais vous savez plaidé pour que l'on
puisse y avoir un mandat de sénateur
avec amanda 2 voilà à mon sens est plus
le cas
très bien ça supposerait une grande
réforme de la constitution que j'avais
suggéré d'ailleurs que je continue de
suggérer bon donc c'est plus le cas je
suis pas parlementaire et ancien
ministre
je crois que j'ai une voix qui ça
s'entend dans le domaine des
collectivités locales donc je me ferai
entendre voilà responsabilités dans le
parti aussi non non je vais beaucoup
donné dans le parti ceci tout ça c'est
une vie que les côtés oui oui je j'ai
d'autres choses à faire mais vous
retrouver quand même notre liberté de
parole ba oui je crois
elle a jamais été trop peut-être
quand j'étais au gouvernement par
solidarité je pense que c'est un conseil
à donner à tous les ministres on doit
être solidaire l'action du gouvernement
il est de tradition en ce moment pour
les hommes politiques d'écrire est ce
qu'on pourra vous lire bientôt je le
pense je le pense c'est pas fini mais
oui vous êtes en train d'écrire alors je
suis en train d'écrire
et on peut vous demander sur quoi
précisément mesure sur le sur la vie
politique sur la période sur mes
anecdotes ma modeste expérience des
anecdotes
je vous donne envie de lire le livre une
version vous avez déjà vous avez déjà un
titre non non mais donc des fonctions
futures voulait pas nous dire non plus
lesquels dans quel domaine associatif
non mais vous venez vous verra on verra
tout ça bon alors une actualité futur
autour de françois rebsamen en tout cas
pas de retour déjà pour que vous m'aviez
à nouveau voilà
exactement d tout à l'heure vous parliez
du non cumul c'est vrai que vous avez
beaucoup bataillé pour pouvoir cumuler à
la fois un type de parlementaire et
d'élu local etc voilà justement pour pas
que les élus soient hors sol qu'est ce
que vous constatez aujourd'hui avec
votre expérience de seul mandat de maire
de dijon bon que ça va te c'est votre
bien mais parce que j'ai une histoire
personnelle qui fait que j'ai été envoyé
dans le groupe que j'ai été ministre etc
mais c'est vrai que on peut avoir
tendance quand on est seulement mère
d'une d'une ville même d'une grande
ville à se sentir un peu isolé si on n'a
pas les réseaux les relais pour innover
notamment qui sont isolées comme cela
oui oui mais alors se faire autour
d'appareils comme vous via les
associations c'est pour ça que on a
regroupé toutes les associations d'élus
des grandes villes dans une association
unique mais qui s'appelle france urbaine
et nous travaillons ensemble dans cette
association très bien merci beaucoup
françois rebsamen d'avoir été notre
invité ce soir sur public sénat dans
notre émission 3 par 3 merci michael
très bonne soirée à tous sur notre
antenne
vaud